have you ever played an FPS and reloaded
a little prematurely but why why would
you do that why would you do any of that
well that's called a Cod reload it's
basically a compulsion to reload when
you don't really have to since you have
plenty of bullets left in your clip and
despite the name you can Cod reload in
pretty much any game with a
gun I reloaded one enemy remaining oh I
keep Rel I literally got reloading
listen what it comes down to is if you
reload when you don't need to it's a Cod
reload reloading after shooting two
bullets Cod reload reloading after
killing someone Cod reload even Destiny
has given a shout out to us fellow
compulsive Reloaders because you might
never know when you need that last
bullet remember switching to your pistol
is always faster than reloading